[Music]
you know why this crowds so excited
hockey in LA right that was sarcastic
applause no the LA Kings this is kind of
a saying they could win the Stanley Cup
tomorrow that's right this is a strange
thing officials in the City of LA have
said if the LA Kings win the Stanley Cup
there are currently no plans for a
public celebration yeah not to worry
though Laker fans have offered to riot
on their behalf they just want to rip
some stuff up yeah they don't care last
night in LA Kings fans taunted New
Jersey Devils fans with giant cardboard
cutouts of Jersey Shore characters
that's true yeah sadly then New Jersey
tried to taunt la fans with cardboard
cutouts of constant sunshine and legal
marijuana
they got us pretty good and both those
things are perfect for hockey they're
kind of perfect for everything they
don't ruin anything don't let's see
what's going on in politics Bill
Clinton's out there stumping for
President Obama yeah yesterday thanks
for voicing your approval yesterday Bill
Clinton told the crowd remember me I'm
the guy who gave you four surplus
budgets yeah to which the Krab replied
that's not what we remember you for
that's not the first image that come
right right Plus budget guys yeah bill
Bill Clinton spoke last night at a
fundraiser for President Obama and I was
amazed at how quickly Clinton's speech
was turned into a campaign ad take a
look I don't think it's important to
reelect the president I'm Mitt Romney
and I approve this message
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Facebook's in the news did you hear this
Facebook may change its accounts policy
and allow kids under 13 to join under 13
yeah when they heard this Chinese
official said great now our workers will
never get anything done
Mel Gibson's father has filed for
divorce you hear that yeah I hope his
parents made it clear to Mel it's not
his fault it's the Jews this was crazy I
heard this according to a new survey
that just came out women who have breast
augmentation have better sex that's true
the study was conducted by men who
answered their wives surveys who she
comes again just get out of here this
week the Vatican denounced a nun who
declared her support for masturbation
she declared her support for
masturbation and they denounced her yeah
the Vatican has ordered the nun into
seclusion which sounds pretty good to
her
don't know why I danced after that one I
just did and I mentioned this before a
big local story the Los Angeles Kings
are up three games to none in the
Stanley Cup Finals the Kings are on the
verge of winning their first Stanley Cup
now we've sent our camera crews out to
capture the madness because you can
imagine people in Los Angeles are going
crazy you take our hockey pretty
seriously